some people think that the the modern
notion of race isn't something we've had
for that long but certainly breaking the
world lovin to us versus them and liking
us and really hating that it is natural
there's there's not tons of studies
including from babies but also from
young children cross-cultural studies
computer simulations of biological
evolution if there's one thing we know
my field knows it's that a propensity to
break the world up into us-versus-them
comes natural so there's even these very
clever so you get a hundred people in
the room you know like you and me
and we all have a coin we all flip right
corning so roughly half is heads half as
tails go into different parts of the
room then we ask so what do you guys
think your tails what do you think it
has group you think we're smarter even
putting myself aside
it so happens a tails group is smarter
the heads group you seem to have like a
bunch of x over there like and and even
you know the most arbitrary ways of
cutting us more sets of psychological
mechanisms where were we where we split
the world
I'm joined by Professor Paul bloom Paul
welcome the show thank you so much for
having me - pleasure to have you on been
listening to a lot of your work recently
some fantastic interviews of Sam Harris
and podcasts that you did a little while
ago but some super interesting stuff
we've been talking about empathy and
about resilience a lot on the show
recently discussed Elliot Kip show gaze
sub two hour marathon performance which
was a very resilient physical feat that
people have seen so we've got a lot a
lot to delve into today but how would
you describe the work that you do if
someone hadn't met you before and didn't
know you so I'm interested in I'm a
psychology professor at Yale and I'm
interested in human nature and so my
work goes from topic to topic and
they're kind of related broadly I'm
interested in pleasure what we like why
we like it I'm really interested in
morality how do we explain our
intuitions about good and evil how do we
explain our who we hate who we admire
and what kind of moral judgements are
good for us like how should we think
moral in their my work kind of blends
into into philosophy and I was my most
recent book against against empathy and
and I'm interested in closer if they're
not addressed in the self I'm interested
in how we think about things that aren't
like us like robots or non-human animals
interested in religion where religious
belief comes from most recently been
interested in suffering so I have a kind
of dream job where I you know I could I
get paid perfectly fine to just ask some
really cool questions and my students
and my colleagues work on them it's must
feel nice to be able to indulge your
intellectual curiosity on a yearly basis
and just keep on changing that up every
so often yeah they haven't fired me yet
it is very nice so you touched on a word
their morality and I think a lot of the
stuff that you're talking about are
questions that people take for granted
or there appear
the is something more people just take
as fact
do you often find when you begin to look
at the first principles or real strip
things back to basics do you find it a
bit of a disconnect or people just
looking at the questions that you're
asking and thinking of what why are you
asking that why are you asking what is
morality or why are you asking what is
empathy it's interesting like my it's a
good question my work tends to fall into
one of two extremes so I'm sometimes
interested in things that are honest to
God puzzling for a lot of people like
you ask people you know what do people
get out of them sadomasochistic sex or
hot saunas or or watching movies that
terrify them and people say no no that's
really cool that we do but some of my
questions and this is what you're
getting it involve questioning things
that we take for granted and William
James a long time ago a great
psychologist you know said it's only to
a scholar can you ask a question like
you know why do people get flushed when
everybody's looking at them why do we
get hungry when we smell something
delicious and these are questions like
you know why does the Apple fall from
the tree you know you got to be in some
way step back and be a scholar and so I
said say well okay sure that happens
that's obvious but but why do we work
that way and so for morality you know if
you right now you walked outside and you
saw somebody slapping child just beating
the crap out of a four-year-old he would
be shocked you probably spring to action
why and it's not enough for you to say
well of course it's just natural as
obvious okay let's spell it out what's
bothering you can you imagine a person
who would find it funny or have no
interest at all and all those are sort
of questions I asked yeah I imagine that
that must get you into some interesting
interesting situations thinking about
some of the times some of the people
that I spend my time with and talking to
and every so often you do you posit a
question or make a point about something
and half of the room sort of turns and
looks and gives you this yeah when they
discover you really know how looking
I think from the outside perspective in
our business yeah I think to fly a flag
for the outsiders I definitely find
those questions more interesting than
the not being able to look at them with
perspective one so let's talk about
empathy it's something that we've
discussed recently on the podcast I
often use the cliche that I have a
crippling level of empathy but then I
don't actually know if I do have a
crippling level of empathy or if I have
a crippling level of compassion and I'd
quite like to work out whether which one
of those it is so some days I regret
calling my book against empathy because
the word empathy has a lot of meanings
and I don't care what you call it it's
so if some people just take empathy to
mean kindness or goodness and I think
everybody should be kind and good and I
don't think there's such a thing as a
crippling level of goodness you should
be as maximally good as you can that'll
be great you just have a lot of goodness
makes you a good person but there's a
more folk there's a set of more focused
meanings that are more interesting in
one sense of empathy which is what I
meant targeting in my book is putting
yourself in another person's shoes
feeling what they feel absorbing their
pain and a lot of people describe this
as a very good thing I actually think in
many ways it could be a very bad thing
and you actually put your finger on one
aspect of it which is you look at the
people who helped other people
face-to-face day to day people who work
firefighters comps nurses doctors
shrinks people who are ER workers
here's what they have in common they're
pretty low empathy they care care about
people they understand people who want
to help people but they could be with
somebody who's screaming and agony and
they're cool with it they don't feel it
and then they you know then they treat
people for nine hours and then they go
home with their family and they order
sushi and they watch TV and and they
don't get upset
now if you have a crippling a level of
empathy you cannot do that you may not
last a week doing that
the pain of others might get to you too
much this is on way of answering your
question whether it's empathy or
something else so I'll ask you if you
whip somebody who's very depressed or
very upset very angry does that affect
you in a way that you're not comfortable
with yes then you have high empathy my
friend and there's nothing wrong with
that there's as long as you keep it
under wraps but it means that there's
certain things you probably are not as
good at doing as others other people
would be you would not do well as
therapists because the therapists you
might spend eight hours a day nine hours
a day dealing with people who are
anxious and depressed and weeping and
and deeply upset and if you can't if you
absorb their feelings if you feel what
they feel you will be run through a
wringer each day so I have a friend of
mine and she's Jesus shrink and so she
tells me she works like 50-minute
session pause 50-minute session pause
1500 and I say that must drive you up
the wall dealing with those people who
are so upset she says to me no I
actually find it fascinating I love
solving her problems I try to work try
to figure this out and everything I find
it exhilarating and she's wired up
differently than me and it's why she
could eat a job and I can
what's your disposition highly empathic
in that way in that and so in some way
when I talk about the problems of
empathy and say there are better ways to
do things better ways to be good and
getting caught up in the pain of others
to some extent it's a sort of self
therapy thing like you know I I'm I'm
talking to myself for a couple of
hundred pages yeah well I opened some
jokes I tell some stories I mean it's
also it's also just just to make sure
it's not I don't want people think my
work is entirely cell therapy it's it's
that a lot of people even people aren't
empathic think that empathy is the way
to go for morality and I discuss in the
book all sorts of reasons why not so one
is the reason that you raised which is
the extent of a personal connection and
impairing your role as a help
but the more general thing is that
empathy is powerfully biased we know
this from everyday life we know this
from a thousand experiments so I'm
looking at you
you know you're a guy user same rough
same skin color ethnicity as me English
speakers similar background whatever so
I could feel for you you're my kind of
guy I could feel your pain if I heard
you were in trouble I could get upset by
it by that
that's how empathy works but what if you
were different
what if you were a different skin color
different gender you didn't speak
English what if you were disgusting
in front of you're a homeless person
there's nothing wash for a long period
of time what if you were frightening all
the other things shut down empathy and
so the extent we can say intellectually
I think that a middle-aged white man
from my my city his life matters just as
much as somebody I will never see in
sub-saharan Africa the extent I could
acknowledge that it means I have to
transcend empathy empathy pushes you to
that that are close to the similar and
as moral reflective beings we say we
could do better than that
so what's what's a pure version of
empathy or what's a less biased version
of empathy so I think by its very nature
empathy is biased empathy is is is is
impure in some way your questions like
saying I complained about racism in
years it was a pure form of racism
racism do not this isn't gonna brief
this racism is gonna be racism yeah but
I think the gist of your question is
what should we replace it with and right
so I hadn't booked against empathy and
the subtitle is the case for rational
compassion and so rational is part of it
which is that you should sort of as you
go through the world if you're a country
if you're an industry if you're an
individual and try to make the world
better for people and use your head to
do so try to figure out once what's you
know what's the best thing to do but
compassion is I think the answer to your
question which is you should care about
people you see this distinction in
Buddhism so
it's very clear it says you know you
want to be a good person you want to be
a helper don't get caught up in other
people's pain instead love them fill it
fill your heart with good cheer and
happiness you know you see these these
buddhist monks and they're radiating joy
even when dealing with people who are in
horrible pain living in squalor and
that's the way to do it compassion and
love but not empathy how do you define
the difference that specific difference
is then between empathy and compassion
is it's simply not putting yourself in
somebody else's shoes that's at the core
of that so so maybe here's a good
example suppose we're really good
friends and I am anxious I'm coming to
you and I'm upset about something I'm
just anxious I'm upset me running fears
and everything if you were to feel
empathy for me
you would feel my anxiety you would
share my anxiety with me and you would
be anxious too but if you were to feel
compassion for me you would see I'm in
distress and you'd want to make my
distress go away and you don't tell me
and this could lead to two very
different responses see if you felt
empathy you'd kind of be there or maybe
crying a little bit with me and so on
and it wouldn't make me any better in
fact in some extent it makes me worse I
now have two problems not just one but
if you felt compassion for me you might
try to cheer me you say dude calm down
take a deep breath it's not as bad you
would be a model for me with your
calmness with your authority this is an
old insight we want what we want in
friends take sadness when you're honored
friends is not something to multiply
your sadness but somebody to replace of
happiness now I don't want to overstate
this or things I think I wrote in my
book that were a bit too strong and I
think there are some cases where we do
want empathy so a good example of this
is anger so suppose I come to you my
friend and I'm furious that somebody
said you know this guy did this and he
did that and how would he treat me that
way and everything and I want you as a
friend not to say huh I really
appreciate your perspectives and I hope
I want you to say he said that to you
with
let's go to this house and and and and
beat the crap and you get angry too
that's what pals do if I'm if I'm
watching a TV show and I'm really into
it I don't want you to sit there next to
me you've seen it I want you to be into
it too I wants to share the feelings and
there's actually psychological work
showing that just two people silently
sharing each other's feelings while
watching a movie or show and everything
there was a pleasure in that and there
was a connection in that so I'm not
against empathy in general I'm do think
you do a lot for us we draw for
relationships could be a great source of
pleasure but as a source as a moral
guide who should I help Hoosier a
country go to war with and everything it
is I think very limited it strikes me
that both emphasis empathy and
compassion can't exist in isolation if I
was the only person on the planet and
the planet was completely whitewashed
except for me is there such a thing as
well I suppose the self compassion but
there's not such a thing as self empathy
is there no it's hard to imagine what
it'd be to put yourself in your own
shoes mental gymnastics is hard to
imagine you would feel much empathy and
compassion for people but they would
just have to be from your imagination
remember these are people you imagine
and you know if there's books left in
this this apocalyptic world you could
feel plenty of empathy for characters
and books yes and and again I think I
think that yeah I love stories I and I
read a lot and and the feeling of
empathy in that sort of imagined a
pleasure is super important I wouldn't
want it that toy immerses you in the
story right exactly you know there are
other things that could immerse you in
the story but you know you often a story
has an engaging character and you put
yourself in his or her shoes and then
you adopt their perspective and you go
through life as them so you know I'm I'm
reading a Stephen King novel now the
Institute and a lot of those this boy
who's trapped up he's been kidnapped and
you really see the world through his
now that's not such an interesting case
to me the cooler case and again now this
gets back to the problem of empathy is
that even a bad character if you get
connected with him you get a donk is
perspective I know you ever watch them
like breaking bad or Sopranos yeah so so
both of these shows at the core at
Walter White honey soprano guys who are
actually not good guys you're not
supposed to take them as like these
wonderful superheroes to follow but once
you have them on the screen and you
think about them and you get absorbed in
them all of a sudden their interests
become your your interests there's no
problem you know you're one of my
favorite books is Lolita by Nava cough
you know and and and the main character
of that Humbert Humbert is a pedophile
he's a pedophile pursuing the affections
of this young girl but by the time
you're 10 pages in the book he's your
guy it's the first person that heard of
you're in this head part of you says you
know this is wrong but part of you
cheers them on and so a good storyteller
can use empathy to cause you to have a
connection with characters who are just
awful and I suppose that manifests
itself in the real world as bias yes yes
all of this manifests itself as bias as
soon as one person steps out of a crowd
and says put yourself in my shoes the
whole world changes and their doors and
doors experimental research on this so
um Dan Madson this great psychologist of
empathy has a study where um where he
tells you about a little girl and she
needs an operation and if she doesn't
operation terrible things will happen to
her but she's uh no there's a lineup a
list and she's low down on the list and
it's a fair list other kids are ahead of
her should you move her up and you say
no if it's a fair or less but then he
has a little twist he says try to feel
what it's like to be her put yourself in
her shoes now things flip and you want
to move her up the list you know I have
hundred people applying for a job and
I'm looking at their files
and then one person comes up to me and
says let me tell you my story and all of
a sudden that person he or she is my
person even though the other 99 also had
stories it's just that that by accident
the one who got to tell me there's got
to sway me and and I think that these
things are morally corrosive I think
they're very natural but the amount of
bias they incur in the world is terrible
and it sets up empathy in a very tight
connection of some like racism I mean
whose stories are you likely to hear
whose whose whose lives are you most
likely to get connected with what people
around you your group your friends your
family and those people are your
psychologists call your in-group empathy
favors to end group but as a moral
person you might say look even if
somebody doesn't have the good fortune
to be one of my friends or to look like
me still that person as it's not moral
value as anybody else and that's what
everything misses mmm it's totally
removing rationality isn't it that's
rank rank order of whatever is first
come first serve or people who need it
the most of a of a group of 100 did you
have a look at how empathy and
compassion would have been used
evolutionarily by our ancestors did you
think about that I did it's a very
interesting question um so the idea of
caring for others some sort of
compassion for others it used to be
thought that this is crazy non Darwinian
like why would we ever have that and
there's a great puzzle for Darwin like
if if nature is red in tooth and claw
survival of the fittest why would we
ever care for another something that's
been a miracle some people said or other
people say we don't really care for
other people can't you know just cynics
all the way down but the neo-darwinian
view got really sophisticated about a
hundred years ago and then people began
to make sense over time of how you could
evolve caring for others so for instance
one simple way is that if you take a
sort of went sit with a genetic
standing there's no hard and fast
division between myself and my children
we share half my jeans and my siblings
who share half my jeans and my cousins
and nieces and nephews and so who share
different fractions my jeans so it
behooves me from an evolutionary point
of view to care about them as well to
really have them matter so that's one
thing we call a kin selection a second
thing is for the reciprocal altruism so
suppose you and I work well together you
know when we when we kill an animal is
too big for either one of us to bring
back we work together and bring it back
we do this repeatedly we both gain from
our interaction well then it makes sense
for me to care about you and so these
mechanisms which aren't infinitely broad
but specific I think I think can help
capture where compassion comes from
empathy is a little bit different nobody
really knows why we have empathy feeling
the pain and feeling the feelings of
others one theory is that it actually
has to do parenting that your connection
with your child or your own baby helps
if you have a truly empathic bond and
one reason to take this seriously
is that the hormones that connect up
with empathy are also involved in
breastfeeding and childbirth okay so
empathy may be an adaptation for dealing
with babies have you defined how empathy
physiologically manifests itself in
someone then um you mentioned others
that there are studies of hormones
there's way in which hormones um can can
elicit empathy and drive empathy what's
interesting is you get a dissociation um
with a separation from compassion so for
instance if in some studies they raise
people's empathy but then these people
become more racist and there's no
contradiction you raise people's empathy
you're not ratcheting up their goodness
what you're doing is you're making them
more connected a toaster connected to
well by the by they'll be less connected
to those they're not connected
- there are studies there are brain
imaging studies and some lovely work
done in Germany where they get people to
be empathic put yourselves in shoes of
others or to get people to care about
others and these show very distinct
neural profiles so I think there's by
now good reason to believe that empathy
and compassion run on different brain
circuitry are connected to hormones in
different ways in a kind of separate and
this is important because if empathy and
compassion were and inextricably linked
than me telling you to give up on
empathy would be kind of crap advice
because then you also wouldn't care
about people at all so it's important
for us to try and work out why the
rubber meets the road between these two
it really is it's important for us is a
murder something like me as as a
psychologist understand it but it's
important for everybody to realize as
they make through their make it through
the regular life where did our moral
thoughts and feelings come from you know
if you say oh you know same-sex marriage
is horrible it's an atrocity and I say
no seems fine isn't perfectly fine I
think each of us should be able to look
and say well why do we feel that way
where's our arguments we should be
reflective about these things you think
this is just what a sort of psychologist
philosopher would say but but I think a
lot of our moral instincts let's do this
let's punish these people let's reward
these people our based on sort of brain
processes and psychological processes
that if we reflect upon them we wouldn't
trust them as much so other things that
people take for granted about our nature
that as you've identified perhaps not
even is an optimal is detrimental or is
damaging and I think I honestly do think
that these sorts of questions I can see
how they're inflammatory I can see how
the suggestion that racism for someone
who's empathic might actually be natural
that they have to work against
because immediately it's such a slippery
slope with bigot at the bottom as
Douglas Maurice ace a bog of bigots at
the bottom that you slip down to say
well racism might be natural it's like
okay well let's think about that we've
spent the vast majority of our
evolutionary history and tribes of what
twenty-five to fifty something like that
absolutely terrified that there's some
pathogen one Valley away that's gonna
infect us and kill us or a tribe that
will come and take all of our food and
rape all of our women or do you know I
mean like yep it's extremely like well
they're not racism is natural it's kind
of a fraught topic it depends what you
think races some people think that the
the modern notion of race isn't
something we've had for that long but
certainly breaking the world lovin to us
versus them and liking us and really
hating that it is natural there's
there's now tons of studies including
from babies but also from young children
cross-cultural studies computer
simulations of biological evolution if
there's one thing we know my field knows
it's that a propensity to break the
world up into us-versus-them comes
natural
so there's even these very clever so you
get a hundred people in the room you
know a you and me and we all have a coin
we all flip right Corning so roughly
half is heads half as tails go into
different parts of the room then we ask
so what do you guys think your tails
what do you think it has group you think
we're smarter even putting myself aside
it so happens a tails group is smarter
the heads group you seem to have like a
bunch of dicks over there like and and
even you know the most arbitrary ways of
cutting us more sets of psychological
mechanisms where were we where we split
the world and you're entirely right that
is that it's natural now of course yeah
be natural it could still be terrible
and so much that it's a bizarre fallacy
to say since it's natural it's good I
think so much of what we do in the world
with great success is
we use our intelligence to sort of
transcend our natural instincts under
Pacific we do this physically you know
I'm wearing contact lenses because my
eyes are bad we take antibiotics to
fight infections and none of this was
natural but we also just psychologically
we also say like for instance we had we
say some forms of bias are wrong so we
make them illegal and we try to work
around them and so on some sort of vote
you know vengeance revenged appetite
revenge it is I think the family natural
but we say don't have it's awful over to
the cops and you know a guy a guy cuts
me off no I can't kill him you know I
give you what about something else
that's very natural that would be a
jealousy induced stealing if you were to
see someone else has something why
wouldn't you why wouldn't you just take
it like oh I want that it seems that
that sort of impulse I think would be
very natural but you can imagine as we
all get together in society we all sit
around as a word this is like a
reconstruction of things and you say you
know all that jealousy induce stealing
we're better off about it and some hands
go up and they say I really like it and
then you say to a person okay what do
you like more a world in which you get
to steal from everybody else but they
get to steal from you our world where
everybody gets to keep their stuff and
presumably people say unbalanced let's
all keep our stuff mm-hmm
you know an example I use in one of my
books is hitting people like you know
sometimes it just feels great to hit
people I wish I could hit people but the
my dislike of someone smacking me in the
head is greater than the pleasure from
hitting other people whenever I want to
so so no heating rule answers flat-out
utilitarian grounds is pretty good yeah
and then you have I suppose the social
enforcement if there's some people that
are hitters and some people that aren't
and then the ones that hit is get found
out by the ones that aren't and then all
the ones that aren't can then say you're
one of the hitters you're not allowed to
be in our group anymore and then it goes
back to tribalism again and we're in the
Deming us group yes yes I mean so much
of modern evolutionary theory
and cultural evolution focuses on
exactly these questions so so as you
know you can't develop a good society
without some way of punishing people who
aren't good if we're all no-hitters and
you run around and smack everybody you
want your life is so much better than
the rest of us so we have to have some
way of putting you in your place and
maybe we punish you
maybe we shun you and then there's
complexities it's like for instance
suppose I'm suppose you do bad stuff and
so you should be punished but punishing
is costly what do we think about people
who could punish but don't you choose
not to do we punish them and if there's
a recent study find that we tend to
punish people who don't punish people
who deserves to be punished it's so
complex isn't it it's so complex one of
the things that I was thinking there
again rolling it forward to sort of the
real the real sort of worst parts of
human impulses is how the development of
pushing people to have consensual sex
and saying that on consensual sex is
something which is absolutely not
allowed because I'm going to guess that
for the vast majority of our
evolutionary history that that also
might not have been the case not
naturally and all of these things you
know when you when you think about it is
when you look at it from a first
principles perspective it really is a an
interesting sort of questions set of
assumptions to to look at as to why
these things happen yeah I mean there's
a general argument that Steve Pinker and
many others have made but Steve Pinker
makes it in the strongest form that in a
lot of ways the world has been getting
better and better and better and better
you know you think the world sucks now
and it made it in many ways it does but
I would rather be this is the best time
in history take class you know last say
30 years I think to be an ethnic
minority to be to be physically disabled
or mentally disabled to be to be a woman
to be a second out to be and and a large
reason why the
to sell this that we've been better at
working out into very problems you're
talking about we're trying to understand
consent we're trying to to figure out
how to balance all sorts of things but
also growing respect for people's rights
in autonomy you know when I was um when
I was young nobody cared about bullying
you know just considered you know kids
smack each other now who cares and now
when my kids go to school people just
really concerned about it they say you
know no kid should be bullied and I'm
thinking about it
yeah it's kind of messed up that gives a
punch each other nobody minds and
similar thing issues about sexual
harassment and sexual assault I think I
think we're learning to become better to
each other now you know plainly there's
a million ways in which we're crap to
each other but we're getting better I
think that's if you're getting better in
part by by smart people struggling with
these questions I suppose is well I
don't want to go down this road because
I've swam down it too much recently but
I suppose that people who take complex
issues like these plant a flag in one
side of the ground or the other and
reduce them down to their most
simplistic forms and then attach them to
a Twitter bio ah really really doing a
disservice to the development and I do
think as I've seen posted more recently
like within the last year to six months
concerns about where our real
intellectual integrity and our real
intellectual power is being placed
recently went to go and see Douglas
Murray give it a talk with Lionel
Shriver literally two days ago for The
Spectator and his primary concern at the
moment is that some of the best minds on
the planet are spending their time
thinking including him his most recent
book the madness of crowds is about this
about socially constructed differences
between gender race sex sexuality and I
do I do wonder how how much further
along we might have been in 30 years
obviously we don't know how how much
more time is going to be embroiled in
some of these discussions but yeah when
you talk about some of the
things that you're doing which are
really uncovering the first principles
of our nature trying to work out real
hard questions about why we are the way
we are and yet some super smart people
Douglas Jordan Peterson Ben Shapiro you
know Sam Harris I get embroiled in these
things that one tweet that he sent could
have been sent about something else that
wasn't that do you get what I mean I I
do I mean you're raising a lot of issues
here so personally I find questions of
of gender and sex to be absolutely
fascinating and under explored but I see
a broader point which is that you know
my experience I spent too much time on
Twitter and and so much of it is people
defending outlandish ly extreme
positions and then you know a sense of
ideological purity on both sides very
strong and then you know that nasty
attacks that don't bring us anywhere
closer and and I'm kind of an optimist
about things I think outside of social
media there's actually an excellent
discourse and in progress but for a lot
of these questions about human nature
particularly questions wrong now sex
revolving around ethnicity and race they
connect very much with our identities
and so they're not abstract theoretical
questions to be bandied about maybe nor
should they be because they affect
people's people's real lives I
understand the point that Jordan
Peterson was making about wanting time
to freedom to describe people as he
chose I also understand anger to God but
people felt that her identity was being
belittled by somebody who had power over
them so this is not getting it at one
way or another but but um these issues
aren't as you say complicated and and to
go back to what we were talking with
racism you know I everybody I know would
say oh well racism that sort of in-group
out-group it's just morally wrong it's
morally atrocious but other forms of
in-group out-group division it's less
clear I love my children much more than
I love you more than that I
for them I would give them resources
much more I would give to you is this
morally wrong
well maybe an extreme utilitarian like
Peter Singer might say well it's kind of
human nature but we could have done
better but I'm inclined to think that
some some sort of in groups like in
groups of family and in groups of
friendship are actually intrinsically
valuable so I would draw a distinction
between me saying I only care I care the
most about white people that's a kind of
a crappy way to live your existence
another man if I was to say I care the
most about my family and friends but
doesn't seem as odious and what do you
think I agree I think the interesting
question is where does the group of
family and friends extend out to at one
point at what point does the rubber meet
the road yes and and our affiliations
are complicated I think I am I think you
know we all have multiple ones I'm a
Canadian I'm Jewish I'm a professor I'm
a man
you know all team useful hockey team in
Canada wouldn't it that's right that's
right
well actually I am I'm wearing a Toronto
Blue Jays t-shirt know if you got a but
but we have multiple affiliations to
some extent are harmless I think sports
teams actually just give it a whirl more
pleasure than any suffering and
sometimes they're there you know when it
comes to religion and race there are
most serious things in the world and and
to go back to it we recognize this
natural we should never ever infer that
that means it's good but it does mean
that we have to be very prepared for an
uphill battle when fighting it did you
literally combat any human nature or
combating what most people you take to
be natural yes and you know there's
different responses so you mentioned Sam
Harris before so I do think there's a
powerful impulse or set of impulses
leading us to be religious one way you
do is I examined us deal with it head-on
you know don't be religious anymore it's
stupid you
something else another hand or other
people say no we're never gonna get rid
of this so let's try to make religions
more reasonable more kind defang them a
little bit a little bit less religious
more spiritual tone them down I think
this guy allowed to boot on argue that
wants to talk I saw he's so I have the
listeners will be familiar I've been
reading his most recent book which might
interest you
an emotional education and thank you it
is I'll link it to you once once we're
done it's absolutely fantastic and very
bizarrely it sorry to interject there
very bizarrely one of the things that
strikes me about his writing and I went
to go and see him speak in London the
other week is how I said I had crippling
empathy he has world stopping compassion
like that guy Oh unbelievable the his
ability to make you feel to not only
show his own vulnerability but to make
you feel like the failings that you have
or like the things that are going on are
as natural as can be it's just it's just
a lovely a really lovely guy and his
most recent book anyone who's listening
that needs something that's a an easy
read but something that's nice and
reflective and emotional education
linked in the show notes below along
with all of Professor blooms books of
course of course when off my books go
check out go check out that one yeah for
sure so one one question actually that
I've been thinking I wonder have you
considered why we still love people who
have passed away it's a question that
got brought up in interstellar actually
if you if you've really sort of listen
because it's a tiny it's like two lines
three lines long in this tiny little bit
and they're talking about one of the
astronauts is is saying I know this
person is alive they're saying should we
should we make the rational utilitarian
choice about what we do with the mission
or should we do this other one and
they're talking referencing a tiny
little bit of evolutionary psychology
and a few of the little bits and pieces
and one of the things that she brings up
is why is it that we love people that
have passed away I wonder whether you'd
considered that
such a good question I was um I was
talking to my my partner other day and
we were talking if she were to die and I
said some way why would have loved you
and she called me and said why the past
tense won't you still love me how old
were you know when you don't exist
anymore can you continue to have
feelings for somebody that doesn't exist
anymore I don't believe in life after
death I you know so so she's really
literally be gone maybe a kind of
saccharine response but one that might
be true which is if you know somebody
well enough in a in a non trivial sense
they continued to live with you they
live inside your head they it's not
merely passive memories it's a way in
which they in miu the world around you
you often see this in bad TV shows and
movies in which I watch a lot of them
where where our guy you know ends up
talking to this departed wife like that
but but I think to some extent they
continue to live with us but I haven't I
haven't thought of that deeper than that
that's a good question
it's a little bit like the character in
your book right you extrapolate out from
that character this person who doesn't
exist who actually never existed but
they live inside of your head right you
you think about what they would have
done there could have done I should have
done if they were in the situation that
you're in yeah yeah yeah we you know our
heads are populated with all sorts of
people and and you know I understand
this is not universal but I do spend a
terrible amount of time having
conversations in my head with people I
know people I want it you know if I'm
experiencing something and I want to
tell something that in future I'll sort
of be narrating it having it so so yeah
our heads are very crowded I agree
moving on to what you're working on now
at some point within the next two years
there will probably be a new Paul bloom
book out yes what can you tell us about
it its title
maybe the pleasures of suffering it may
be a sweet spot and a not helpful some
helpful subtitle like suffering pleasure
and the good life and it will be about
why we are drawn towards suffering and
we'll look at it two levels one level is
the pleasures we get from certain forms
of sufferance or anything if it's or
mundane things like we eat spicy foods
that burn our mouths we we like saunas
and hot baths and rollercoaster rides
Halloween's coming and people gonna go
to haunted houses that is terrified to
be scared some people engage in
consensual the sex involving some degree
of pain and degradation humiliation
while we're all those appetites come
from there so paradoxical there's not a
huge puzzle to go back to sort of things
that are explained you know somebody
would look at you funny if you say I
wonder why people like ice cream and
they say well dude ice cream is
delicious you know okay that's it's not
even the details need to happen but
that's that makes sense but then you ask
you know why do people like eating spicy
food so hot it makes them so poor sweat
and they're crying
some people do that's half the book
another than half of the book is sort of
asking a broader question which is what
do we want out of life and I want to
argue it's not just pleasure or even
happiness it's a deeper form of meaning
or purpose and for that suffering arises
again because we know we're living a
meaningful life when we're suffering to
some extent any project any because any
project of any value requires effort it
requires the possibility of failure
it requires difficulty often conflict
often anxiety you know having kids is
the pure example of this
which is you've got to be an idiot
everybody knows if you're gonna have
kids it's going to be tough but this
toughness is tied in some tightly with
its reward if you told me about
something you did and you said it was
easy-peasy no pain at all no surfing at
all I would guarantee you you're not
gonna take much of value from it how
hard could it have been how significant
could it have been so so I think
meaningful difficult life pursuits will
require suffering it's wrapped in a very
notion of difficulty I think there's
some really broad implications for how
people live their lives they're talking
about overcoming obstacles and and
suffering certainly I know for me that
when my life gets too comfortable that's
the only time that a little existential
sort of tick at the back of my head
starts to it starts to appear but when
I've constantly working on something
that is both challenging and worthwhile
that really doesn't occur yeah that's a
that's one aspect of what I'm interested
in so um this guy me Holly
Csikszentmihalyi developed the concept
of flow which is what you're alluding to
and a flow state is when you're just
really into something and it's just
perfect it's just right it's if it's too
easy it's boring it's just fun that's
boring what I like watching TV watching
bad TV but if it's too difficult it's
frustrating and you just sick of it flow
state is just a Goldilocks state right
in between where if you do it right you
lose track of time you struck the level
of difficulty as such it captures you
and captures your consciousness people
in these states say you know you go for
a long time you're working on your book
or or or some project and then you
forget to eat
you forget the e you lose you lose track
of women's you don't sleep whatever and
that's that sort of that's one aspect of
what I'm talking about but you don't
have that unless you have difficulty
because that needs to be a challenge it
needs to be
that's right I'm trying to relate that
to people that like to get spanked with
leather things during sex and well it
fits I want to see I want to hear the
flow States for BDSM I was gonna say
sufferers there but it's not it feed
some funds well I'll make I'll make the
connection for you actually yeah I think
I can't wait to hear they're not gonna
be quite the same story but here's but
here's a connection it's not mine on
this by this ecologist Roy Baumeister
which is one theory of what goes on with
BDSM is that it liberates you from your
consciousness so if you're like a lot of
people I'll speak for myself I'll speak
for you but I've been in my head all the
time my kind of my anxieties my nerves
my self-talk my memories my
responsibilities things I'm ashamed of
things you know all studies in might
have one way to empty your head of all
of this is to to get really good at
meditation and maybe after 10 years of
meditative practice you could empty out
that head of yours for a while but
here's a way somebody could do it really
quickly they could slap you in the face
really hard now you're not gonna like
being slapped in the face but I'll tell
you when that slap hits for second
afterwards your head is clear you're not
you know there's this great quote by am
you know by a dominatrix saying nothing
captures one's attention more than a wit
and so the idea is of being 1:32 BDSM is
that what the physical level something
isn't a psychological level it's an
escape from yourself it's in some way
it's the opposite of meditation
meditation you sit you've been
you know you're stuck in your head
observing and trying to deal with it and
like that the BDSM along with things
like intense exercise some drug
experiences extreme sports extreme
sports yeah you know I'm not a big
martial arts guy but the first time I
ever did Brazilian Jiu Jitsu I'm they're
rolling or somebody first time in my
life and this goes on for a while and
I'm like you know I'm no good at it but
this you know get a twist into a pretzel
by a guy and but I realized afterwards
that during that I don't know three
minutes five minutes I thought of
nothing else I thought my head was clear
and um and that's I understand this one
BDSM to do for you there's not many
situations now you know to the listeners
the the tuned in at the moment think
about the last time that you didn't have
any thoughts other than the one thing
that you were doing or other than any
one thing for more than about 30 seconds
yeah if you held a gun to my head right
now and told me when that was that I'd
have to do a fair bit of work and so if
you're ever fortunate enough to get
mugged
there you go maybe I'll have that
something now now obviously there's bad
sides to very much but the wooden little
wonderful meditative practice though of
but the one good side is during that
period you're in the moment you know and
and that moment of the slap now you know
there's all other things going on and
this is your mileage really may vary but
um but I did some rock climbing again
I'm not sure my son is a serious rock
climber I'm awful at it but it's the
same thing the mixture of fear the need
to solve a problem the physicality at
all you're not thinking of anything else
but you don't have that unless you have
a task that's powerful enough to take
away from your consciousness that to
devote your entire focus one way to do
that is through extreme difficulty
another way that adds extreme pain
and that's what they haven't caught it I
tell you what I didn't know I did not
think that you were going to be able to
draw those two together but you've
managed to do it oh thank you
yeah again going back to the going back
to the extreme physical exercise thing
I'm CrossFit and myself have a lot of
friends that do it and the place that I
see my athletes that my friends put
themselves into on a weekly basis a
daily basis in the gym is Jordan who's
the owner of the gym that we have and
it's a yearly ritual that the final work
out of the open which tends to be a very
particular kind of time domain power
endurance workout which is like a sort
of a to Cairo which kind of area may be
a seven to ten minute or five to ten
minute just go for go and every single
year there's a it's almost like a meta
meme now about the fact he's straight
outside to go and throw up in the drain
but he does it every single year he'll
go and do it and this guy is able to
choose to put himself in that place in
front of a crowd of people who all know
that he's going to throw up and he knows
that he's going to throw up and he
doesn't do it any other time and it's
this workout and you just think why but
I know why I know why and that's one of
the situations I can say when when you
haven't got anything left there is there
is something that's odd this oddly so
satisfying about that so have you looked
again to ask the same question have you
looked evolutionarily why why that's the
case the evolutionary benefit that kind
of thing I have looked I am not really
that close to finding an answer I'm
excited to find one I think great this
is a great question I mean there's
something else going on in suffering at
your storage bring you have which is
sometimes it's social so sometimes it's
social in that you're signaling
something about yourself your friend is
signaling that you put in Olli has
doesn't it be proud of it's not a bad
thing to show you your friends to you'd
be stealing your courage your endurance
your piety there's all these religious
rituals involving showing stuff or
anything it's meant to show your your
you're subservience to God your love of
your of your fellow ethnic group your
fellow religious group so suffering that
serve many purposes the Puritan work
ethic I suppose like that exactly
exactly yeah well you see that as well
in the hustle and grind culture of young
entrepreneurs now right mm-hmm they sort
of Gary Vaynerchuk approach of sleeping
five hours and I and when you want to
succeed as much as you want to breathe a
lot of that's signaling a lot of it's
signaling and then of course there's I
imagine in these communities is always a
counter signaler somebody who says you
know look yeah I just got nine hours of
sleep I'm gonna work with that and I'm
gonna go for a walk in the park and what
they're saying is I am so good I don't
you know it's basically the equivalent
of the young calm guy going to a meeting
you know wearing wearing a hoodie and
sweatpants which is you guys have to
wear suits to saves everything I am so
and and you know there's no such thing
as not giving a [ __ ]
there's just signaling you don't give a
[ __ ] that is that is a fantastic quote
there's no such thing as giving a [ __ ]
there is just signaling that you don't
give a [ __ ] I don't get it I'm gonna use
that yeah you know I think increasingly
about as I spend time speaking to guys
like yourself and Robin Hanson from
elephant in the brain and Rick Hanson
and a lot of these people who think
about William von Hippel guys it's
really do think about sort of why we
come from that and Robert Greene was on
recently and this than any other
increasingly now and I wonder whether
this is the same for you understanding
people's motivations with at least a
little bit more nuance than I do
probably a massive amount more
understanding than I do
I see people sometimes like WWE
characters you know like they've got
this persona that they're playing and
this is the brand that they've attached
their flag to yeah and when you draw it
back you can see the lineage of why that
happened that oh well this
it's my particular ethnic group body
shape background working class whatever
it might be
do you phlegm do you find yourself
becoming sort of fascinated with the
people that you meet and trying to learn
that the backstory and stuff like that
do you try and apply a lot of the things
that you learn to the people that you
meet I'm really interested in the people
I meet and building what use what you're
saying I think on social media there's a
a sort of narrowing down stripping down
and people's characters so people are
always always without exception much
more interesting in person than they are
in social media it's not the same for
writers actually I've I've never left
writers who I admired her and I kind of
wish I never meant to write it I love
them I like the books better yet the
books are so sophisticated gorgeous
world view and you meet the writer and
he's kind of Schmo like you like me I
mean I like both of us I like both of us
perhaps um but but yeah there is um I
think Robin Hanson is right about how
pervasive signaling is I think he's
wrong was saying and that's all there is
what she often says I think that um that
but but he's right to think that there's
a backdrop in everything we do online
and in person where we're not only doing
it we're also saying and this is me
doing it I'm the guy who does it so so I
tell you oh brexit frightens me and I'm
telling you rectify things it does
frighten me I want you know what but I'm
also signalling I am the kind of guy who
would say breakfast frighten me and and
and and there's that working for both
those of us were psychologically healthy
and only the the mentally ill or
toddlers don't do this we're social
beings so we are sensitive to Hanna we
portray ourselves and you're right I
think that because of this was often a
forceful oversimplification one of the
you know I've I've had to experience
many times of getting an argument or
somebody online or something and
thinking what a dope and then you meet
them in there
far smarter you would have expected and
they're far more nuanced and you know
it's in a sentence their fault sometimes
people's what it proves to signal is a
sort of no penis
service of some other goal they wanted
appear to be true believers or morally
pure or so on you know you go back to
the moral thing or just you you tend to
get stuck up and thinking everybody else
has this sort of set conventional moral
views of a sort whatever your community
is my community is pretty liberal so
everybody has the same sort of liberal
views but you meet somebody close up and
you become friends with them and soon
leery as everybody has at least one way
in which no morality isn't what you'd
expect
you know they're extremely right-wing
but yeah they're very Pro trans I was
talking to you I need a transfer you
know they're they're extremely fees but
they hate unions and you know you find
this and it's always interesting again
that lack of nuance in conversation is
not allowing people to be take their
ideologies or their worldviews piecemeal
that you need to swallow it whole so
that's right and that's a straight but
nuanced to some extent isn't something
you could display in front of a largely
unfriendly crowd and if you have any if
people are looking at you in social
media a lot of are looking just to watch
you fail and embarrass yourself and
contradict yourself and perform some
sort of heresy and so it's not the best
time to fly your nuance you know you bet
it better in the presence of friends or
people who you trust
yeah because new ones to a crowd which
is not on your side will probably come
across like a lack of conviction that's
right that's right a lack of conviction
incoherence you've been saying I don't
know to an unfriendly crowd is risky do
you follow
apologies by the way are famously risky
which is you know every says to
politicians
apologize apologize apologize and then
when they do apologize for Esther lips
they said oh yeah better he was wrong a
little boy you can't do right for doing
wrong there yeah I wonder whether
because this it's a cliche now to say
long-form conversations are missed this
is the reason for the podcasting
platform
taking this growth because there is a
hunger out there for people who want but
I do wonder whether it's less about the
long-form conversation and more to do
with the fact that it is a open
battleground to discuss ideas without an
audience which is there immediately
giving you feedback which immediately
biases you towards saving saying things
that might get a laugh or get or
whatever because he's still gonna have
want that at least a little bit from the
other person you're gonna want to say
things that make you somewhat XYZ to the
other person but I wonder whether these
the increasing popularity of these sorts
of conversations online is something to
do with the fact that it is this nice
petri dish environment to have a
discussion where new ones can be
discussed in a way I never thought about
that but I think you're right I think
you're right I think one of the appeals
of our podcast is just listening to a
conversation where ideas could be
sketched out and you know as you know
podcasts come in different flavors
there's sort of a straight interview
sometimes where somebody as the word has
a list of 50 questions in front of them
and they try not to be too obvious as
they look down and they do that and like
that
but then there's doing what we you and I
are just talking and and when done right
I think that's very powerful I agree it
the topic itself might be interesting
but I think you're right that more
generally it gives me kind of a warm
feeling to hear people talk about
interesting ideas like this is how we
should be doing these things I think so
and I think as well as you've said that
as everyone's seen online right like
Douglas Murray has this line where he
says um people can lose their careers
for saying the thing
for not saying the thing that nobody
said until yesterday and yes the problem
with that is that in a sample size
that's only thirty second segment
perhaps on the news or that's whatever
it is now 300 characters or something
that's on Twitter yeah it's very easy to
take things out of context now that's
not to say that I've had clips from this
podcast that get taken out of context
but when you spread it across the sample
of a one-hour conversation someone can
say something that's wrong or there
isn't fully formed and then the other
person might press them on it and then
that allows them to you know I mean it's
it's less the peaks and troughs are more
spread out yeah yeah yep this is what
that's I agree with that it's another
reason why podcasts of roughly is length
seemed like a good idea speaking of
which that's around about the length
that's right so let us sum let us crack
on and I will I will let the listeners
have a look at some of your work which
will be linked in the show notes below
if they want to hassle you online and
send you tweets 300 300 characters long
why should why should they had it's at
Yale and is there a website or a blog
that you that you haven't now you want
me to find my faculty website but I
don't I don't run a blog or anything
like that
well Twitter now can be that right it's
whether it is kind of that yeah that's
right exactly
hey thanks for having me on this was
great it was so much fun I can't wait I
know you've got as you mentioned before
we started you have some some chaos
occurring in on your side of the pond
from like November 2020 but yeah I
really uh as soon as you've got the the
next book out I absolutely love to have
discussion I'm sure the audience will be
through as well yeah be terrific I'll be
back amazing thank you very much to the
listeners if you enjoyed the episode you
know what to do like share and subscribe
down below links to against empathy how
pleasure works all of Professor blooms
socials and everything else we've spoken
about will be in the show notes but
but for now thank you very much
[Music]